et avec nous pour en parler en direct
par skype e régis chamagne ancien
colonel de l'armée de l'air expert en
géostratégie bonsoir régis
chamagne à vos côtés également par skype
régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france merci à vous également d'être la
régie c'est sur ce plateau dimitri de
kochko président de l'association stop
russophobie merci d'être avec nous donc
on apprend ce soir que joe biden et ses
homologues européens tiendront une vidéo
conférence à rendez-vous qui fait suite
donc à la réunion des 27 ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'ue régis le
sommier à quoi doit-on s'attendre dans
ce contexte extrêmement tendu que l'on
vient de décrire avec nos reporters
alors contexte évidemment extrêmement
tendue ça c'est une réalité maintenant
il faut voir un petit peu où se trouvent
les uns et les autres et où ils en sont
notamment par rapport à leur propre
opinion publique vous avez dans cette
crise des gens qui agitent le fanion qui
soit que ce soit joe biden ou boris
johnson et on sait qu'aujourd'hui ces
deux personnages subissent dans leur
propre opinion publique et au vu des
calendriers électoraux
je parle de joe biden en particulier une
pression énorme un déficit de popularité
et il y a aussi eu de la part des états
unis une série de revers dans le monde
et une position de faiblesse qui a été
manifeste après le départ d'afghanistan
donc aujourd'hui la surenchère verbale
qui vient des états unis parce qu'on se
rend bien compte que la russie a
peut-être certes masse et impute 120000
troupes aux frontières de l'ukraine il y
a en effet des tensions et en effet des
signes eux que la russie fait des
manoeuvres est lassé des manoeuvres
d'ailleurs depuis 2014 puisque cette
guerre n'est pas terminée il faut bien
le préciser et que les accords de minsk
qui avait été établie cette même année
n'ont toujours pas été appliquée donc il
y a voilà il y a toujours cette cette
tension mais il y a une donne aussi au
niveau des opinions publiques on le voit
très bien notamment à travers l'attitude
de l'allemagne l'allemagne aujourd'hui a
fait cet accord avec la russie et
dépendantes quelque part du gaz russe et
elle regarde ce qui se passe à l'est
avec beaucoup plus de mesure jusqu'à
dire la vérité parce que le chef d'état
major de la marine allemande finalement
a traduit une bonne partie de ce que
pensent les allemands justement par
rapport à la considération dont il
estime que les russes devraient avoir
droit aujourd'hui régis prenons les
choses dans l'ordre c'est vous le voulez
bien on va en parler injustement du
calmant parce que c'est vrai qu'ils ont
un certain intérêt les allemands
notamment au niveau de leur dépendance
avec le gaz évidemment en europe mais
enfin on entend quand même que les
européens ce soir ils sont un petit peu
dans l'embarras dimitri de kochko parce
que josette borel dit voilà il il
appelle à éviter les crises de nerfs
l'érection alarmiste c'est un petit peu
une pierre jetée dans le jardin des
états unis ça
ne l'est pas si loin des coûts doit
quand même obéissance au m mais il
n'empêche que c'est vrai combat le chaud
et le froid ça c'est incontestablement
et je dirais la réaction allemande la
réaction de borel mais aussi une
conférence de presse qu aient lieu à
kiev cet après-midi disant qu'elle mon
jeu tension pas trop de panique parce
que ça vanne des conséquences
financières pour nous
aurait tendance à
calmer le jeu justement qui est un jeu
médiatique effectivement totalement
comme vous le disiez parce que la
réalité des choses c'est pas du tout une
menace d'invasion de l'ukraine par les
russes c'est une négociation sur la
sécurité européenne
demandée par les russes aux etats unis
puisque c'est de lui que tout dépend
c'est d'eux que de l'auto dépend pour
leur garantir notamment qu'il n'y ait
pas de missiles pointés sur la russie a
juste à la frontière russe quant aux
troupes qui serait masse et elles sont
massés sur 400 km à l'intérieur du pays
en russie où est-ce qu'elles doivent
être les troupes russes sinon en russie
en revanche je suis effectivement 120
mille hommes ukrainien du côté de la
frontière russe mais du côté ukrainien
est évidemment à la frontière des
des républiques autoproclamées du
donetsk et de lougansk et c'est là
qu'est le danger c'est que l'on risque
et 7,5 ont peur les russes aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on risque une grosse
provocation qui est préparé justement
par ce tintamarre médiatique dans la
presse occidentale et compris françaises
malheureusement et qui risque d'être une
provocation notamment à l'occasion des
jeux olympiques de pékin comme ça s'est
passé en 2008 n'oubliez pas quand
monsieur saccage feely a attaqué
l'ossétie du sud donc il ya un mauvais
souvenir là qui reste est une grosse
crainte effectivement des russes
aujourd'hui le ministre défense choïgou
a annoncé a expliqué où se massaient les
troupes de l'otan le renforcement des
troupes de l'otan notamment en ukraine
en géorgie en moldavie mais aussi au
japon
alors justement qui m'a tendu et la
déception que vous venez nous en faire
l'otan qui a annoncé placer un des
forces on a tenté envoyer des navires et
des avions de combat rien que ça pour
renforcer ses défenses en europe de
l'est vous propose d'écouter le
communiqué de l'otan
les alliés de l'otan mettent des forces
en état d' alerte et envoie des navires
et des avions de chasse supplémentaires
au déploiement de l'otan en europe
orientale renforçant ainsi la dissuasion
et la défense des alliés alors que la
russie poursuit son renforcement
militaire en ukraine et dans les
environs et or régis chamagne 1 dans le
détaillant ce communiqué indique que le
danemark par exemple on voit une frégate
dans la mer baltique s'apprête à
déployer quatre avions de chasse f16
espagne des navires rejoint les forces
n'avoir de l'otan pareil pour la france
qui s'est déclarée prête à envoyer des
troupes en roumanie sous le commandement
de l'otan
les pays bas envoient deux avions de
chasse f 35 en bulgarie c'est important
de lire les détails parce que c'est vrai
que ça sonne un petit peu pas très bien
toutes ces places ne sont pas des mots
d'amour loin de là et ça n'apaise pas la
situation comment doit-on lire ce
message
je pense qu'il s'agit là d'une
provocation
d'abord il faut bien rappeler que
avant de lancer ce que les occidentaux
l'ont taux plein qui matent hommes la
lumière poutine et le président chinois
a dit en ont parlé ça veut dire que il
ya eu des accords déjà entre la chine et
la russie qui désaccord un rapprochement
très très fort qu'on n'avait jamais vu
offrir ce qui signifie que toutes les
actions diplomatiques entreprises par
l'un ou l'autre du pays est avalisée par
l'autre donc
en lançant cet ultimatum entre
guillemets vladimir poutine savez très
bien quelle réaction pourrait être celle
de l'otan des états unis et j'imagine
qu'il a déjà anticipé les différentes
possibilités qui vont qui sort
actuellement on est dans un espèce de
provocation chacun celle du muscle c'est
un peu comme avant un combat de boss
voulez où les boxeurs se regardent dans
les yeux ya une chose pour si c'est
assez d'essence dans le combat oui ou
non parce que c'est vrai que c'est ce
que tout le monde et quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui la presse et les médias
français c'est vrai que on avait
tendance à se poser la question
clairement aujourd'hui et qu'on appelait
ici ou là à une désescalade extrêmement
rapide ans
je ne pense pas que voir conflit
personnellement parce que encore une
fois si vladimir poutine alors c'est cet
ultimatum qui est tout simplement de
proposer un nouvel ordre mondial de
sécurité
c'est bien ça va bien au delà de la
question du cren
c'est
ce qui l'a anticipé action possible de
le temps et en plus sur le plan
militaire il a les moyens de neutraliser
complètement l'action de temps il faut
se souvenir
de la supériorité en matière de guerre
électronique que possède la russie et
dans le livre de stratégie aérienne que
j'ai écrite explique de façon très
claire et logique que la supériorité en
1/4 et électronique est un préalable à
toutes les autres supériorité sur le
plan militaire donc actuellement
vladimir poutine enfin la russie possède
les moyens vous neutraliser les centres
de commandement de l'otan et de travis
et leurs actions je pense que c'est un
de la parole autant ses tapas ou d'odeur
espèce de dernier baroud d'honneur et là
on voit à travers les actions de chaque
pays quels sont les toutous et quels
sont ceux qui veulent prendre un peu de
recul par rapport à leurs maîtres
américains et gestion au sommet on voit
les réactions vous avez commencé à nous
parler tout à l'heure de l'allemagne un
règlement rossi nous évoquer cette
affaire avec le chef de la marine
allemande qui avait qualifié d' ineptie
les intentions prêtées à la russie à
l'allemagne qui a toujours refusé
d'ailleurs de livrer les les armes des
armes à l'ukraine 1 au grand dam
d'ailleurs du gouvernement ukrainien et
là un instant emmanuel macron qui vient
de proposer je cite un chemin de
désescalade à vladimir poutine paris se
dit attentif à ne pas créer d'ambiguïté
de volatilité supplémentaire qu'est ce
que ça dit c'est que dans le fond
personne n'a vraiment intérêt à un
conflit et eon premier lieu l'europe
n'est ce pas oui je pense que personne
n'a envie d'aller faire la guerre en
ukraine ça c'est une réalité à part
quelques néo conservateurs du côté de
washington et quelques-uns de leurs
alliés un peu partout en europe et même
en australie en ferait cependant vous
avez quand même une caste qui existe et
qui est encore un très puissante mais
dans la réalité là on est on est dans
vraiment dans du langage diplomatique
dur on est dans du positionnement en
effet ce qui a été dit sur la pertinence
de l'otan en fait c'est aussi une
question d'une manière aussi de devoirs
où on l entend aujourd'hui cette
alliance qui n'a plus d'ennemis qui a
qui n'a plus d'ennemis en tout cas
qu'ils avaient qui avait joué son rôle
de protection de l'ordre de l'ouest
pendant la guerre froide rôle qu'elle
quitte dont elle était parvenue à elle
était parvenue ces objectifs c'est à
dire qu' il n'y a pas eu d' invasion de
l'ordre de l'ouest mais depuis la fin de
l'urss se pose la question de la
pertinence et de la réalité de l'otan
aujourd'hui et deux sas à sa survie
emmanuel macron lui même avait déclaré
que l'otan était en état de mort
cérébrale et souvenez-vous que le
prédécesseur de joe biden en
l'occurrence donald trump avait dire il
y en a marre parce que nous payons et
engrossé les états unis qui payent pour
cette cette alliance donc là il ya une
manière on voit qu'on le voit bien dès
que de toute façon dès que la question
de la défense européenne et est remise
au goût du jour et bien vous avez
immédiatement le secrétaire de l'otan
qui arrivent et qui dit mais non il n'y
a pas besoin de défense puisque l'otan
la sueur l'otan est une une à monstres
sans sens comment sans véritable
objectif est aujourd'hui serait bien qu
il serait bien temps et on le voit bien
avec les déclarations allemandes parce
que c'est pas là c'est pas ce que ce
qu'a dit le chef d'état major de la
marine allemande et est totalement
bien-fondé totalement réfléchi et n'est
évidemment pas le seul il s'est sacrifié
en le disant puisqu'on ne peut pas
critiquer quand on appartient à
l'alliance et qu'on ait le comment le
chef d'état major de la marine donc il a
un peu payé pour ce langage de vérité
est ce que fait manuel macro est aussi
dans les fêtes ez pai c'est une
prolongation de son discours à bruxelles
l'autre jour la france est aujourd'hui à
la tête de l'union européenne et la
france de marquer sa différence aussi
n'oublions pas aussi que la france a
toujours énormément de mal à digérer ce
qui s'est passé avec le contrat la
subtilisation du contrat de sous marins
australiens et cette façon d'avoir été
négligé par les états unis donc là il ya
beaucoup de questions qui se posent et
cette crise ukrainienne révèle aussi des
fractures révèle aussi des questions sur
le positionnement géostratégique des
etats-unis dans le monde et aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de voix dissidentes le chat fin
de la marine allemande qui donne du
grain à moudre on porte parole du
kremlin
encore une fois qui parle dimitri de
kochko de fausses informations de
mensonges publié qui augmente les
tensions on va pas parler de la guerre
en irak mais enfin se souvient quand
même que pardon mais à une guerre qui a
été déclenchée sur la base d'un mensonge
américain ça a été suivie par une partie
des alliés pas par la france on pourrait
peut-être se retrouver dans ce cas de
figure est à voir que cette fois ci une
union européenne un peu plus prudente
encore une fois que bon oui ça peut être
ou un baroud d'honneur
effectivement de l'otan ou bien la
préparation médiatique à une provocation
pour attaquer les républiques de
lougansk est de donetsk le baroud qui va
dans ce sens du baroud d'honneur c'est
un le fait que les américains vont
donner une réponse aux demandes russes
de sécurité mais ils posent comme
condition que ce ne soit pas publié donc
ça risque de mécontenter certains ou de
leurs alliés ou bien dans les camps
politiques aux etats unis avant les
midterms et ça c'est très important
comme élément
deuxièmement ce qui va dans ce sens du
baroud d'honneur c'est que déjà tout en
montant la mayonnaise au niveau
médiatique johnson les polonais ont
annoncé qu'ils n'interviendraient pas en
ukraine les grandes les anglais ont
effectivement envoyé des armes un petit
peu obsolète aux ukrainiens en en
faisant évidemment grand cas mais ça
c'est pour l'instant arrêtée là et
évidemment que c'est contradictoire mais
ce qui va dans le sens de la volonté de
provocation et donc du risque de guerre
c'est effectivement le vieux rêve d'une
bonne partie des extrémistes craignant
et de pas mal de faucon sans doute dans
le dip state américain de vouloir
provoquer une guerre effectivement
jusqu'au dernier l'ukrainien des
américains serait qu'on serait prêts à
combattre les rues jusqu'au dernier en
ukrainien
justement en attaquant ses république et
en réalisant le vieux rêve vie de la
krajina c'est à dire le nettoyage
ethnique faut faire comme les croates
qui ont chassé les serbes qui habitait
dans cette province de la krajina depuis
déjà trois siècles en fait hélas ces
régions là n'oubliez pas donetsk est
lougansk ce sont des régions de russie
qui ont été a donné à l'ukraine par
lénine et les bolchéviques donc
effectivement ils peuvent parler de
nettoyage ethnique mais ce nettoyage
ethnique ni évidemment ne serait que
autorisé par les états unis parce que
les ukrainiens en soi ne peuvent pas
prendre de mesures par eux mêmes
c'est que voulait pas intervenir en
ukraine il n'empêche il a eu un petit
peu un discours musclé sur les pas de
son allié américain je vous propose
d'écouter boris johnson le premier
ministre britannique on s'est battu elle
nous devons également faire passer le
message qu'envoie hier l'ukraine d'un
point de vue russe va être une
entreprise douloureuse violentes et
sanglantes et je pense qu'il est très
important que les gens en russie sache
que cela pourrait être une nouvelle
chute et me dit
quelque chose ça ne peut pas être in
tchétchénie il en rêverait bien sûr mais
aujourd'hui les troupes russes sont
totalement différentes et comme vous
disiez évidemment que les rues des
troupes russes n'interviendront pas en
ukraine et tout se réglera d'abord par d
une guerre électronique effectivement
pour neutraliser les installations
ukrainienne et et otanienne qui agirait
contre les républiques de donetsk et en
plus éventuellement par quelques tirs de
missiles comme les russes ont montré en
syrie qui savait faire régis yaman
vous êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic
oui je fais d'accord avec tout ça
je pense que les personnes de
l'intérieur cellulaire d'autant que les
russes
enfin ma voix d'un député je crois donc
ont annoncé que si on entrait dans une
vierge il frapperait non pas les
endroits d'où viendrait des coups mais
il frapperait les donneurs d'ordre donc
donc ça veut dire qu'il pose clairement
une menace sur ceux qui sont aux côtés
de l'atlantique bien au chaud et qui
s'imagine être à l'abri il ya une ligne
rouge là qui est clairement délimitées
qui est ko les a clairement posé et qui
fait que personne personne n'a intérêt à
ce qu'ils aient une guerre qui se
déclenche
régis le sommier une fois qu'on a hâte
on se dit que personne n'avait intérêt à
ce qu'une guerre se déclenche comment on
en sort là parce que ça fait un petit
moment que ça discute et on trouve pas
franchement d'issue
on va attendre la semaine prochaine avec
eux la réponse écrite des américains
demong russe justement de non adhésion
formelle de l'ukraine à l'otan parce que
c'est quand même ça qui est le principal
enjeu là aujourd'hui il ya la loi
l'ukraine et ya évidemment aussi la
géorgie et les américains se sont
engagés justement à répondre aux
demandes russe qui avait été clairement
écrite formulée est donc là il ya une
sorte de deux suites de ces négociations
ensuite il ya la question de l'armement
nucléaire qui est qui et qui est en fait
ce que souhaiteraient les russes et un
comment une sorte d'entente globale
autour d'eux dans lequel l'ukraine et
qu'une partie finalement des enjeux et
je pense qu'il va falloir attendre et
que cette rhétorique est là pour faire
monter les enchères elle est
malheureusement elle se pose en terme
militaire puisqu'il ya quand même une
augmentation et c'est pas nouveau le
l'afflux d'armes alors on a dit oui en
effet les britanniques ont accepté dans
dans dans d'envoyer à nouveau un
remarque d'ailleurs que les britanniques
depuis qu'ils sont sortis de l'europe
joue de mieux au mieux leur rôle d'allié
indéfectible des etats-unis ils ont
retrouvé une sorte de liberté qui leur
permettent d'être à l'avant-garde des
demandes américaines et en plus ça
satisfait boris johnson qui est lui
empêtré dans une crise intérieure qui
m'a probablement lui côtés d'écouté sa
sa place dans les semaines qui viennent
donc là il ya voilà ya un mélange dans
jeux intérieurs et extérieurs qui sont
qu'il faut prendre en compte comment on
en sort je pense que ça sera oui ça sera
une négociation mais vous savez on
parler de la crise syrienne tout à
l'heure les américains et les russes ont
négocié pendant des heures se prend dans
la bataille d'alep c'était john kerry
contre le sergueï lavrov à l'époque il
ya eu des moments de tension comme ça
énorme c'est pas inhabituel et côte est
pourra-t-on souhaité un débouché je
pense que la russie dans cette histoire
a comme objectif principal d'être
reconnu comme un acteur essentiel et
incontournable sur la scène
internationale c'est aussi le retour
d'une diplomatie russe et d'une volonté
de régler un certain nombre de problèmes
et puis il y a encore aussi pour les
etats-unis une volonté aussi de peser
sur les choses donc tout ça devrait à
mon sens pouvoir se solutionner par la
diplomatie espérons-le parce que je me
dis encore une fois moi je pense qu'une
guerre en pour l'ukraine une guerre à
l'est si l e elle se développe au delà
des la question d'une guerre
électronique serait quand même
désastreuses pour l'europe et pour
l'ensemble du continent eurasien
dans l'ensemble autant menace
essentiellement de de nouvelles
sanctions de la russie les grosses
sanctions dont elle menacé un arrêté le
gaz du nord stream 2 mais dans ce cas là
l'europe va être privé et surtout
l'allemagne bien évidemment d'une source
d'énergie très importante et vous avez
vu ce qui se passe avec le prix du gaz
actuellement donc c'est nous qui allons
encore une fois payé nous européens et
puis le deuxième ce serait d'arrêter le
système swift mais vous le souhaite se
dire les échanges m'ont écrit monétaire
bancaire etc mais est ce que ça veut
dire que tous les jours il y aura des
avions qui vont amener à moscou ou
importées à moscou 3 pas 300 millions de
dollars pour payer le gaz le pétrole et
tous les matières premières qu on achète
à la russie mais c'est impensable alors
qu'on est en train d'essayer de
supprimer l'argent fiduciaire nelly
numéraire les espèces non mais c'est
totalement incohérent merci en tout cas
à tous les trois ans régis chamagne
dimitri de kochko sur ce plateau et
régis le sommier merci de nous avoir
apporté votre point de vue